[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on a quatre dans les mesures qu'elle
soit restée cs merci on va parler bien
sûr de ces génies est-ce que tu regardes
les émissions comme les marseillais la
bataille des coupes alors aujourd'hui je
vous le dis on a la liste des futurs
prix nobel de la télévision française
mais je vous le dis ils sont là et ils
sont dans la bataille des coupes sur tf6
aujourd'hui on va s'intéresser plus
particulièrement un génie hors norme en
plus je le kiffe vraiment cela d'or
s'est dit ladd dylan il a deux passions
dans la vie
aller au petit coin et manger des
mollusques alors forcément il en sa vie
de tous les jours ça se ressent un petit
peu voilà la meilleure expression de
dylan depuis le début de l'aventuré
regarde je comprends que pour fêter ce
soit réduire de très grands mais comme
moi puisque c'est vrai que voilà je mets
beaucoup la pression voilà elle me suit
quoi qu'il arrive c'était proche aidant
la moule
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est à dire la meilleure phrase à la
fin de la saison pour moi c'est la
meilleure recette
tatata bien dénicher dans l'âme ou cela
qui fait alors quand dylan n'est pas en
train de chier dans la moule comme il
dit il passe sa journée coller à sa
fiancée fidji alors sauf que comme dans
tous les couples
il ya des roues il ya débat mais chez
eux il ya beaucoup plus de débats en
fait voilà hélas hier soir entre dylan
et fidji c'est parti en cacahuète total
je vous le dis regardez regardez surtout
bien la fin de la brouille
vous allez voir que les autres coupons
faire une analyse qui est vraiment c'est
une très très bonne analyse des autres
groupes regarde la raison par exemple
bien sûr bien ses engagements karl
verser dans la compréhension cinéma en
personne personne parce que pour les
contrats je pense que
bravo vous êtes fait perdre megas je
pense qu'elle est on travaille dans ce
cas les contrats là je l'avoué ça te dis
ça je ne me trompe pas là dessus je le
plus posa alors vous l'avez compris je
suis fan de ce couple dont dans tous les
domaines
ils sont au dessus du lot et notamment
dans un domaine très pointu c'est la
zoologie vous allez voir qu'ils sont
capables de vous décrire avec précision
l'anatomie du serpent alors moi je m'y
attendais pas j'ai regardé une émission
comme ça et franchement j'étais bluffé
regard des opérations combres à 2.0 demi
finale
son contrat ne peut avoir aucun faux pas
pourquoi parce que le combat ne fait pas
[Applaudissements]
certains n'a pas de jambes mais deux
sexes elle disait qu'elle s'installe
mais reviennent pas et ça tombe mal avec
fans à l'école mais voilà et qu'elle
allait dire c'est vrai qu'a t'on jamais
ça fait dix ans qu'elle fait la même
émission il a fait la parade haché et la
n118 et le coq
[Rires]
on m'a dit le coq et après fait quand
j'étais que le 10 km signée ben mandat
mais c'est pour ça qu'on aime
oui c'est des classiques ça servait un
concert il m'a demandé ma main comme
j'entendais rien j'ai dit oui
[Rires]
pour sa comptabilise à lui gérard bile
anecdotes sur serpent donc merci de
l'avoir répété mais moi je trouve en
revanche le coût pardon de l'émission là
sur les couples moi je casse l'ambiance
mais ça me fait pleurer enfin oui mais
alors là là c'est vrai que tu es là pour
casser l'ambiance c'est vrai lorsque
mais merci parce qu'en fait je trouve
que ça décrédibilise complètement la
notion de couple qui devient une sorte
de gadget mais oui mais non mais c'est
dramatique parce que pour les jeunes qui
regardent ça sert il oui moyenne car on
croit que forcément un homme et une
femme vont forcément se coller dessus on
perd c'est insultant mais ils ont pas le
recul que vous avez la chieuse mais
pathologie là dedans la sélection sympa
rend compte que c'est plus vraiment des
téléréalités et même le public qui s'y
connaît - qui n'est pas dans les médias
c'est que c'est quand même surjouée et
même le saint aulaye croire non il y en
a qui n'ont mais non mais ils sont et
moi et moi je les trouve plutôt
sympathique moi j'y crois pas que ça y
est moins pire que ça